we got lots of big immigration stories
to get to tonight
first up California's governor Gavin
Newsom continues his war against
low-income and middle-income Americans
by building a more powerful magnet to
draw illegal aliens to his state this
time by giving them state Medicaid
benefits we are the most untraditional
fornia not just as governor of
California now we're providing health
care for everyone regardless of
immigration status if you believe in
universal health care you believe in
universal health care we wanted to be
here to celebrate what's right in this
country and contrast our approach with
the approach coming out of Washington DC
all right that gravely voice of his does
not make him any more persuasive what's
right he said is he kidding us all right
Gavin you have runaway homelessness in
your states a total crisis right now
most notably in San Francisco in LA it's
creating filthy and infectious
conditions for Californians and
especially those low income citizens who
don't send their kids to fancy private
schools for some reason this state and
particularly the local officials in
Southern California in in Los Angeles
the City Council the mayor refused to
acknowledge what this is and in the
meantime they perpetrate a hoax and I
cannot understand why I'll say and the
government led by Gavin give it away
Newsom it's so pathetic at addressing
this crisis that businesses in LA are
now planting thorny plants and other
stuff around their buildings to try to
keep the homeless away why Californians
keep voting in these destructive and
delinquent politicians is completely
beyond me
my friends it's all a Democrat induced
disaster instead of focusing on things
like I don't mental health and
infectious disease problems that are
plaguing the state the pilot
kitchens in California are spending 98
million dollars more to extend health
care to illegals by the way that's on
top of the billions they already spend
on them the whole country will soon
become the next California if these
Democrats get their way we do ourselves
no favors by having 11 million
undocumented people in our country be
unable to access healthcare raise your
hand if your government plan would
provide coverage for undocumented
immigrants all right as we consider the
national implications of this open
borders mania we should not forget that
sanctuary policies like California's
have led to tragic results attracting
and protecting the most dangerous
elements of the illegal population
police officers murdered in cold blood
by an illegal alien deported five times
who kept returning back to the state
others have been gunned down in the
prime of their lives the horrific rape
of a young teen by an immigrant who was
arrested twice for illegally entering
the country but California's Democrat
leadership doesn't like talking about
those victims instead they focus their
time on vilifying our Border Patrol and
ice now these California Democrats and
those seeking national office need to
recognize that they were elected to
represent the American people and this
country not the people from elsewhere
who violate our laws to enter our
country